20th anniversary of smallville just
happened and um
you know they got the blu-rays out and
you know all the stuff tom and i did
some press and
uh
what do you think it's pretty it's
pretty crazy it's been 20 years now you
got involved in what season
five four
four
yeah season four so you were with the
show for
seven six out of the ten years
seven what do you remember
what good memories do you honestly have
like do you come to you right away not
that you have to search for but what are
some some moments that you have that you
remember
i was happy every time i was walking for
my trailer to set i was excited i
remember marching there in my little
fry boots ready to march in and
just be in in the studio and have fun
and i mean i really literally
loved it the only times i was ever
really pissed is when it was three in
the morning
and i was in a strapless dress and i was
cold
and welling or you were wearing like
[ __ ] suits but otherwise i
i loved it i was so excited to go in and
do the different scenes i thought the
sets were like when i first got there
and i looked at these real sets because
i had no idea what to expect i thought
it would be like
ting like a tin can or something and a
couple chairs right like and then you
walk in and it's a real barn and it's a
real house and
you know the vibe of everybody wanting
to produce and do something really cool
together that was excited about it i
thought that that was really neat
um
i liked the stunts i loved that every
time i went in i did something different
like every episode i was doing something
completely different now in the first
couple of years
i was like i called myself the bum bump
check which one was like basically
say the punchline ha ha boom
yeah like there'd be a really important
heartfelt scene and then i would come in
at the end and ruin it somehow then then
i'd march off
which was fine i was like that was
probably all i could handle at that
point i was so stressed out
um i love the small backlight
that that means
the back lot when we got closer to the
last few years we actually had a full
lot in the back it made me feel like we
were on the warner brothers studio you
liked that and it was just
yeah we could do all our walking talks
and
i honestly am not cheesy person i really
loved it you just enjoyed it all but i
remember i remember you very bold
that stuff annoyed me yeah of course the
rain and cold of vancouver but i
remember you also being
um
incredibly lovable charming great to
work with but i do remember that
nervousness sometimes
and that's a little bit much the
pressure no it was the pressure you put
on yourself it didn't it didn't affect
anybody else it was just affecting you
in your head because you just had to be
and i have that issue too or i have to
be great i have to be great it has to be
great i have to get this i i don't want
you know let people down i don't want to
let it's just like it's it's
it's that insecurity i've talked about
with a lot of people and you know you
try to again you try to be cool and
you're like all right did i do a good
job am i you sure you got it you know
are we moving on are you sure you want
to move on or you're like shut the [ __ ]
up
but you
i'm talking about me
i had that all the time and part of it
now i realize and
is my waiver and you know you're hearing
this people talk about this all the time
but you know you go through therapy and
you realize so much stuff
um
from your childhood and it isn't even
the fault of the parent trying to do
things or not doing things it's
it's a child's response to their
environment my environment was very
rule-based